there was one
chuck norris
it's an american reference yeah uh cell
that made it out of the vents
right or
like the first one so imagine then that
there's one cell gets out and it takes
over the world it gets out in the water
it's like floating around we're deep in
the ocean somewhere yeah but actually
two cells got out
um and they appear to have got out from
the same
vent
because they both share the same code
and everything else so unless all the
you know we've got a million different
common ancestors in in all these
different vents so either they all have
the same code and two cells
spontaneously merge from different
places or
two two different cells fundamentally
different cells came from the same place
so either way what are the constraints
that say not just one came out or not
half a million came out but two
came out that's kind of a bit strange uh
so how did they come out well they come
out because
what you're doing inside event is you're
relying on the electrical charges down
there to power this reaction between
hydrogen and co2 to make yourself grow
and when you leave the vent you've got
to do that yourself you've got to power
up your own membrane and so the question
is well how do you power up your own
membrane
and the answer is well you need to pump
you need to pump ions to give an
electrical charge on the membrane so
what do the pumps look like well the
pumps look different in these two groups
it's as if they they both emerge from a
common ancestor as soon as you've got
that ancestor things move very quickly
um and
and divergently why does the dna
replication look different well it's
joined to the membrane the membranes are
different the dna replication is
different because it's joined to a
different kind of membrane so there's
interesting you know this is detail you
may say but it's also fundamental
because it's about the two big divergent
groups of life on earth that seem to
have diverged really early on it all
started from
one organism
and then
that organs just start replicating the
heck out of itself
with some mutation of the dna so like
there's some
um there's a competition through the
process of evolution they're not like
trying to beat each other up they're
just
they're just trying to live they just
replicate us
yeah well you know let's not minimize
their yeah they're just trying to chill
they're trying to relax
there's no but there's no sense of
trying to survive
they're replicating i mean there's no
sense in which they're trying to do
anything they're just a kind of an
outgrowth of the earth you might say of
course the aliens would describe us
humans in that same way
they might be wrong primitive life it's
just it's just ants that are hairless
mostly hairless overgrown ants overgrown
ants
you